what I want to do in this video now that
we have displacement as a function of
time given constant acceleration and an
initial velocity I want to plot
displacement velocity I should say final
velocity and acceleration all of those
as functions of time and just so that we
really understand what's happening is
the ball is going up and then down
so we know this is our this is our this
is our displacement as a function of
time we know what our final velocity is
going to be as a function of time we
talked about it in the last video our
final velocity is going to be our
initial velocity our initial velocity
plus our acceleration times change in
time right if we start at some initial
velocity the extend then you multiply
the acceleration times time this is this
part tells you how much faster or slower
you are going to go then your initial
velocity and that will be your I guess
you could say your current velocity or
the final velocity at that point in time
and of course our acceleration we know
our acceleration is pretty
straightforward the acceleration due to
gravity is just going to be negative 9.8
meters per second squared once again
negative being the convention that it is
in the downward direction our initial
velocity is going to be in the upward
direction nineteen point six meters per
second so let's let's plot these out a
little bit let's plot these out so the
first this the first graph I want to do
right over here will be my displacement
versus time so this axis right over here
is going to be time or maybe Becket's
call this the change in time axis
actually let's just call it time let's
just call it time and then this axis
right over here I will call displacement
and let me put some markers here so
let's say that this is five meters 10
meters 15 meters and 20 meters and then
in the time this is 0 this is 1 this is
2 this is 3 and this is 4 seconds so
this is in seconds right here this is
meters 5 10 5 10
15:20 and then so this is displacement
this is displacement displacement to
graph and I want to at the same time is
that I want to do a velocity graph so
let me draw my velocity graph like this
I'll do it a little bit different so
this is because the velocity will be
going up and down so we need to have
positive and negative values here but
time will only be positive and so once
again I care about one second two
seconds three seconds and four seconds
in time and velocity I'm going to call
this this is going to be ten meters per
second 10 meters per second this is 20
meters per second this will be negative
10 meters per second and this will be
negative 20 meters per second and so all
of this is in meters per second this
right here is velocity velocity this
right here this axis right here is time
so this is my velocity graph my velocity
graph and why don't we just throw an
acceleration graph over here although
that's to some degree the easiest of
them all so the acceleration graph the
acceleration and I'll just do this right
from the get-go because we're going to
assume that acceleration is constant so
this is one second two seconds three
seconds and four seconds into it and
then let's say let's call this negative
10 negative 10 and all of this is in
meters per second squared and so we know
our acceleration is negative 9.8 meters
per second squared so the acceleration
the acceleration the entire time over
the four seconds the acceleration over
the four seconds is going to be that's
about negative 9.8 it's going to be that
it's going to be a constant acceleration
the entire time but let's figure out
displacement and velocity so let me draw
a little let me draw a little table here
let me so I'll do in one column I will
do change in time or you could sometimes
you can do that as time let's figure out
what our final velocity is or I should
really say our current velocity or
velocity at that time and then in this
column I'll figure out
our displacement is what our
displacement is and I will do it I will
do it four times zero one two three four
or change in time so when zero seconds
have gone by when one second has gone by
when two seconds three seconds and four
seconds have gone by actually let me
call this the change in time axis
because it is essentially how many
seconds have gone by so this is my
change in time axis and let me make it
clear that this graph er I didn't label
it here this is my acceleration graph
acceleration and I'm going off of the
screen all right so let's let's fill
these things out so at time zero what is
our what is our velocity well if we use
if we use this expression right here at
time zero or delta T is equal to zero
this expression right here is going to
be zero and it's just going to be our
initial velocity and at the in the last
video we gave our initial velocity is
going to be as nineteen point six meters
per second so it is going to be nineteen
point six meters per second and let me
plot that over here at time zero it is
going to be nineteen point six meters
per second what is our initial
displacement at time zero our change in
time zero so you look at this up here
well our delta T is zero so this
expression is going to be zero and this
expression is going to be zero so we
haven't done any displacement yet when
no time has gone by so we have done no
displacement so we have done no
displacement we're right over there
now what happens after one second one
second has gone by what is now our
velocity well our initial velocity right
over here is nineteen point six nineteen
point six meters per second that was a
given and our acceleration is it's a
negative 9.8 meters per second squared
so it's a negative right over there and
then you multiply that times delta T in
every situation so in this situation
we're going to multiply it by one
because delta T is 1 so we get nineteen
point six minus 9.8
that gives us exactly 9.8 meters per
second and the units work out because
you multiply this times seconds this
gives you meters per sec
so nineteen point six meters per second
minus nine point eight meters per second
one of these seconds goes away when you
multiply it by second gives you 9.8
meters per second so after one second
our velocity is now half of what it was
before so we're now we're now going 9.8
meters per second let me draw a line
here 9.8 meters per second now what is
our displacement so you look up here and
let me rewrite this displacement formula
with all the information that we know so
we know that displacement is going to be
equal to our initial velocity which is
nineteen point six and I won't write the
unit's here just for the sake of space
times our change in time times our doing
that same color so you see what's what
times our change in time plus one-half
let me clear it one-half times negative
9.8 meters per second squared so
one-half times a is going to be actually
I can rewrite this right over here
because this is going to be negative 9.8
meters per second times one-half so this
is going to be negative 4.9 all I did is
I took one-half times negative 9.8 over
here one half times negative 9.8 this is
important and this is why the vector
quantity start to matter because if you
didn't if you put a positive here you
would you wouldn't have the object
actually slowing down as it went up
because you would have gravity somehow
accelerating it is it went up but it's
actually slowing it down it's pulling
it's it's accelerating it in the
downwards direction so that's why you
have to have that negative right over
there that was our convention at the
beginning of the last video up is
positive down is negative so let's focus
so this part right over here negative
4.9 m/s squared times delta T squared
times delta T times delta T squared and
this will make it a little bit easier
although we'll still let me get the
calculator out so when one second has
passed when one second is passing in my
trusty ti-85 out when one second splats
the displacement is nineteen point six
times one well that's just nineteen
point six minus 4.9 times one squared so
that's just minus 4.9
minus 4.9 gives us fourteen point seven
meters so fourteen point seven meters so
after one second the ball has traveled
fourteen point seven meters in the air
fourteen point seven so that's roughly
over there now what happens after two
seconds I'll do this in magenta so after
two seconds our velocity is nineteen
point six minus nine point eight times
two times two this is two seconds have
gone by well nine point eight times to
get nine point eight meters per second
squared times two seconds gives us
nineteen point six meters per second so
these just cancel out so we get our
velocity is now zero so after two
seconds our velocity is now zero
actually let me so let me make it so
it's this this thing should be this
thing should look more like a line I
don't want to make you get a sense so
this is so let me just draw the line
like this so our velocity is now zero
after two seconds what is our
displacement our displacement so we're
literally at the point where the ball
has no velocity at exactly two seconds
so it's kind of gone up and it's right
for what important for just that that
exact moment in time it is stationary
and then what do we have going on in our
displacement we have nineteen point six
let me get the calculator out for this
we can do it by hand but for spit sake
of of quickness nineteen point six times
to nineteen point six times two seconds
minus four point nine times two seconds
squared this is two seconds squared
I lost the calculator times two seconds
squared so that's times four so that
gives us nineteen point six meters so we
are at nineteen let me defend a magenta
we are at nineteen point six nineteen
point six meters so after two seconds we
are nineteen point six meters in the air
now let's go to three seconds so after
three seconds well our our velocity is
now I'll just get B it's nineteen point
six meters per second minus nine point
eight
times three and we could do that in our
head but just to verify it for us let me
get the calculator out it's nineteen
point six minus nine point eight times
three that gives us negative nine point
eight meters per second
negative nine point eight meters per
second so after three seconds our
velocity is now negative nine point
eight meters per second what does that
mean it's now going in the downward
direction at nine point eight meters per
second so this is our velocity graph and
then what is our displacement at this
point so once again let's get the
calculator out if you're getting the
hang of this and any time I encourage
you to pause it and try it for yourself
so now what is this is a little okay so
I'm looking at my displacement I wrote
it right over here so our displacement
where delta T is three seconds nineteen
point six times three minus four point
nine times and this is delta T so this
is three seconds we're talking about
when delta T or change in time is three
seconds so that's squared so times nine
and that gives us fourteen point seven
meters so it fourteen point seven meters
so after three seconds we're at fourteen
point seven meters again and so we're
the same position we're at one second
but the difference is is now we're
moving downwards over here we were
moving upwards and then finally what
happens after four seconds well what's
our velocity well let me just get the
calculator out although you might be
able to figure this out in your head our
velocity is going to be nineteen point
six minus nine point eight minus nine
point eight times times four seconds
times 4 which is minus nineteen point
six meters per second minus nineteen
point six meters per second so we're
going our magnitude of our velocity is
the same as when we initially threw the
ball except now it's going in the
opposite direction it's now going
downwards so it's now going downwards
and what is our displacement get the
calculator out
well so we have our displacement is
nineteen point six times four four
seconds have gone by minus four point
nine
times 4 squared which is 16 so times 16
which is equal to 0 our displacement is
0 we are back on the ground we are back
on the ground so if you were to plot its
displacement you would actually get a
parabola a downward-opening parabola
that looks something like this doing my
best to draw it relatively neatly so I
check it to a better job than that I'll
do a dotted line dotted lines are always
easier to adjust midstream so the if you
draw it if you plot this displacement
versus time it looks something like this
it's velocity is just this downward
sloping line and then the acceleration
is constant and the whole reason why I
wanted to do this is I wanted to show
you that the velocity the whole time is
decreasing at a constant pace and that
makes sense
because the rate at which the velocity
increases or decreases is the
acceleration and the acceleration based
are based on our convention is downwards
so that's why it's decreasing we have a
negative slope here we have a negative
slope of negative 9.8 meters per second
squared and so just to think about
what's happening in this ball for this
ball or this rocket I know this video is
getting long as it goes through the air
I'm going to draw the vectors for
velocity so I'm going to do that in
orange or maybe I'll do that in blue so
velocity in blue so right when we start
it has a positive velocity of nineteen
point six meters per second so I'll draw
a big vector like this 19 point six
meters per second that's its velocity
then after one second it's 9.8 meters
per second so it's half of that so then
it's maybe it would look something like
this 9.8 meters per second then at this
peak right over here it has a velocity
of zero then as you go to three seconds
it has nine point it has the magnitude
of its velocity is 9.8 meters per second
but it is now downwards it is now down
where it so it looks like this and then
finally right when it's when it hits the
ground it has right before it hits the
ground it has a negative velocity of
nineteen point six meters per second so
it would look like it would look like
this roughly like this if I use the same
scale over here but what was the
acceleration the entire time well the
entire time the acceleration was
negative it was negative 9.8 meters per
second squared and I'll do that in
orange so the acceleration over here
negative now I want to do that in orange
the acceleration was negative 9.8 meters
per second squared acceleration negative
9.8 meters per second squared negative
9.8 meters per second squared the
acceleration is constant the entire time
this last one is negative 9.8 meters per
second squared it does not change
depending where you are in the curve
when you're near the surface of the
earth so hopefully that clarifies things
a little bit and gives you a good sense
of what happens when you throw a
projectile into the air